we begin this morning with russia's
relentless artillery attacks across
eastern ukraine as it bombards key
cities in an effort to capture as much
of the ukrainian east as it can at the
same time russia is apparently holding
two americans both military veterans as
prisoners a third american also a
military veteran is m.i.a
the three joined ukrainian forces to
fight the russians on friday russian
state television showed video of two of
the men alexander drewkey and andy
nguyen both from alabama
chris livesay is in the city of kharkiv
in northeastern ukraine with the latest
on this chris good morning
good morning jeff yeah russian media has
wasted no time showing images of those
two captured americans their loved ones
say they started by offering assistance
to ukrainians but wound up fighting
right here in the harkeev area on the
front line
in russian hands and speaking in russian
unmistakably under duress but thank god
they're alive says alex drewkey's mother
bunny i was just relieved he looks
not like he's been beaten or mistreated
that was really encouraging to me
drewkey and andy nguyen both former
military from alabama were fighting in a
squadron of foreign volunteers alongside
the ukrainian army one member told us
they were all nearly killed by a russian
vehicle when drookie and nguyen
destroyed it with an rpg saving their
lives last week but then they went
missing says wyn's fiance joy black and
that they missed their rendezvous point
and that had been a few days prior
they had gone out and searched
they didn't find anything
and later i found out they'd done drone
searches
and still found nothing no traces
this week they turned up on russian
media where the hosts mocked their
families as they pleaded for their lives
they went to ukraine to kill russians he
says but ended up being captured by the
same russians
ukrainians are in their fourth month of
war
dude that was right behind you but more
and more americans are fighting in it
now a third american fighter has gone
missing on the front lines retired
marine captain grady kirpazi a 20-year
veteran reportedly disappeared after
taking small arms fire in the harsan
region for those captured their fate
rests in the hands of russia where
lawmakers have called for the death
penalty you could say anything to the
people who he's with right now what
would you say to treat both of the boys
inhumane you know give them humane
treatment and um
[Music]
and just you know take care of them
now as for other americans considering
coming to ukraine to fight president
biden has told them to stay home russian
media says they'll be treated as
mercenaries and not according to the
protections of the geneva convention
dana
not good news for their families there
chris thank you
concern is mounting that the senate may
not be able to meet its self-imposed
deadline to finalize its details for a
bipartisan gun reform deal 10 democrats
and 10 republicans announced a
compromise package last week to curb gun
violence in the wake of recent mass
shootings but after several meetings
this week lawmakers are still at odds
mainly over two provisions including
what's known as the boyfriend loophole
that prevents domestic abusers from
owning guns christina raffini is at the
white house with more christina good
morning
good morning dana well following those
shootings in ivalde and buffalo
lawmakers vowed to come together and
come up with common sense reform but the
longer it takes those senators to get
that deal to the floor for a vote the
longer its detractors have to pick the
legislation apart
as a teacher
i've imagined that scene in my own
classroom again and again
speaking to the national pta convention
friday first lady jill biden implored
congress to take action on gun control
we need to fight now
for the lives of our children and for
the safety of our schools this week a
bipartisan group of senators announced
they'd agreed to a basic framework of a
deal including enhanced background
checks for gun buyers under 21 and new
funding for school mental health and
security programs i'm more hopeful than
ever
that we have a handle on all of the
issues
but lead republican negotiator john
cornyn had to defend the deal to a
hostile gop convention back home in
texas
but i will not
under any circumstance support new
restrictions for law abiding gun owners
that will always be my red line and some
republicans like fellow texan ted cruz
are already expressing concern about the
inclusion of so-called red flag laws
anyone that tries to take away our
second amendment rights i will stand and
fight to defend our liberties lead
democratic negotiator connecticut's
chris murphy says the group of senators
has committed to move forward with the
deal i have continued confidence that we
can
write that framework
into uh into text and we can have that
before our colleagues next week
president biden has endorsed the
framework of this deal so has senate
minority leader mitch mcconnell but
lawmakers still have to work out rules
about what they want to do there's a
provision that would ban domestic
abusers from buying guns they're also at
odds about what to do about sending
money to states that have red flag laws
that allow courts to confiscate guns
from people they believe pose a risk
michelle
a lot of work ahead christina thank you